you
[Applause]
five years ago I received a phone call
that would change my life I remember so
vividly that day it was about this time
of year and I was sitting in my office
remember the Sun streaming through the
window and my phone rang and I picked it
up and it was two federal agents asking
for my help in identifying a little girl
featured in hundreds of child sexual
abuse images they had found online they
had just started working the case but
what they know that what they knew was
that her abuse had been broadcast to the
world for years on dark websites
dedicated to the sexual abuse of
children and her abuser was incredibly
technologically sophisticated new images
and new videos every few weeks but very
few clues as to who she was or where she
was and so they called us because they
had heard we were a new nonprofit
building technology to fight child
sexual abuse but we were only two years
old and we had only worked on child sex
trafficking and I had to tell him we had
nothing we had nothing that could help
them stop this abuse it took those
agents another year to ultimately find
that child and by the time she was
rescued hundreds of images and videos
documenting her rape had gone viral from
the dark web to peer-to-peer networks
private chat rooms and to the web sites
you and I use every single day and today
as she struggles to recover she lives
with the fact that thousands around the
world continue to watch her abuse
I have come to learn in the last five
years this case is far from unique how
did we get here as a society in the late
1980s child pornography or what it
actually is child sexual abuse material
was nearly eliminated new laws and
increased prosecution's made it simply
too risky to trade it through the mail
and then came the internet and the
market exploded the amount of content in
circulation today is massive and growing
this is a truly global problem but if we
just look at the u.s. in the US alone
last year more than 45 million images
and videos of child sexual abuse
material were reported to the National
Center for Missing and Exploited
Children and that is nearly double the
amount the year prior and the details
behind these numbers are hard to
contemplate with more than 60% of the
images featuring children younger than
12 and most of them including extreme
acts of sexual violence abusers are
cheered on in chat rooms dedicated to
the abuse of children where they gain
rank and notoriety with more abuse and
more victims in this con in this market
the currency has become the content
itself it's clear that abusers have been
quick to leverage new technologies but
our response as a society has not these
abusers don't read user agreements of
websites and the content doesn't honor
geographic boundaries and they win when
we look at one piece of the puzzle at a
time which is exactly how our response
today is designed law enforcement works
in one jurisdiction companies look at
just their
form and whatever data they learn along
the way is rarely shared it is so clear
that this disconnected approach is not
working we have to redesign our response
to this epidemic for the digital age and
that's exactly what we're doing at
thorne we're building the technology to
connect these dots to arm everyone on
the front lines law enforcement NGOs and
companies with the tools they need to
ultimately eliminate child sexual abuse
material from the internet let's talk
for a minute
let's talk for a minute about what those
dots are as you can imagine this content
is horrific if you don't have to look at
it you don't want to look at it and so
most companies that have or law
enforcement agencies that have this
content can translate every file into a
unique string of numbers this is called
a hash it's essentially a fingerprint
for each file or each video and what
this allows them to you to do is use the
information in investigations or for a
company to remove the content from their
platform without having to relook at
every image and every video each time
the problem today though is that there
are hundreds of millions of these hashes
sitting in siloed databases all around
the world in a silo it might work for
the one agency that has control over it
but not connecting this data means we
don't know how many are unique we don't
know which ones represent children
who've already been rescued or need to
be identified still so our first most
basic premise is that all of this data
must be connected there are two ways
where this data combined with software
on a global scale can have
transformative impact in this space the
first is with law enforcement helping
them identify new victims faster
stopping abuse and stopping those
producing this content the second is
with companies using it as clues to
identify the hundreds of millions of
files in circulation today pulling it
down and then stopping the upload of new
material before it ever goes viral four
years ago when that case ended our team
sat there and we just felt this deep
sense of failure is the way I can put it
because we watched that whole year while
they looked for her and we saw every
place
in the investigation where if the
technology would have existed they would
have found her faster and so we walked
away from that and we went we did the
only thing we knew how to do we began to
build software so we've started with law
enforcement our dream was an alarm bell
on the deaths of officers all around the
world so that if anyone dare post a new
victim online someone would start
looking for them immediately
I obviously can't talk about the details
of that software but today it's at work
in 38 countries having reduced the time
it takes to get to a child by more than
65%
and now we're embarking on that second
horizon building the software to help
companies identify and remove this
content let's talk for a minute about
these companies so I told you 45 million
images and videos in the US alone last
year those come from just twelve
companies twelve companies forty five
million files of child sexual abuse
material these come from those companies
that have the money to build the
infrastructure that it takes to pull
this content down but there are hundreds
of other companies small to medium sized
companies around the world that need to
do this work but they either one can't
imagine that their platform would be
used for abuse or to don't have the
money to spend on something that is not
driving revenue so we went ahead and
built it for them and this system now
gets smarter with the more companies
that participate let me give you an
example our first partner imager if you
haven't heard of this company it's one
of the most visited websites in the u.s.
millions of pieces of user-generated
content uploaded every single day in a
mission to make the internet a more fun
place they partnered with us first
within 20 minutes of going live on our
system someone tried to upload an own
piece of abuse material they were able
to stop it they pull it down they report
it to the National Center for Missing
and Exploited Children but they went a
step further and they went and inspected
the account of the person who'd uploaded
it hundreds more pieces of child sexual
abuse material that we had never seen
and this is where we start to see
exponential impact we pull that material
down it gets reported to the National
Center for Missing and Exploited
Children and then those hashes go back
into the system and benefit every other
company on it and when the millions of
hashes we have lead to millions more and
in real
time companies around the world are
identifying and pulling this content
down we will have dramatically increased
the speed at which we were removing
child sexual abuse material from the
internet around the world
but this is why it can't just be about
software and data it has to be about
scale we have to activate thousands of
officers hundreds of companies around
the world if technology will allow us to
outrun the perpetrators and dismantle
the communities that are normalizing
child sexual abuse around the world
today and the time to do this is now we
can no longer say we don't know the
impact this is having on our children
the first generation of children whose
abuse has gone viral are now young
adults the Canadian Centre for child
protection just did a recent study of
these young adults to understand the
unique trauma they try to recover from
knowing that their abuse lives on 80% of
these young adults have thought about
suicide more than 60% have attempted
suicide and most of them live with a
fear every single day that as they walk
down the street or they interview for a
job or they go to school or they meet
someone online but that person has seen
their abuse and the reality came true
for more than 30 percent of them they
had been recognized from their abuse
material online this is not going to be
easy but it is not impossible now it's
going to take the will the will of our
society to look at something that is
really hard to look at to take something
out of the darkness so these kids have a
voice the will of companies to take
action and make sure that their
platforms are not complicit in the abuse
of a child the will of governments to
invest with their law enforcement for
the tools they need to investigate a
digital first crime II
when the victims cannot speak for
themselves
this audacious commitment is part of
that will it's a declaration of war
against one of humanity's darkest evils
but what I hang on to is that it's
actually an investment in a future where
every child can simply be a kid thank
you
[Applause]